Even fucking do.
How so? A piece of shit guy that used to be my roommate.
Things really fell apart. His father died
and then he like lost his fucking mind.
And then I feel like he needed somebody to be angry at,
and that was gonna be me.
So he started like using all my shit in the house and not replacing it.
And I was like, hey bro,
I get that your dad died, but like,
I'm a single mom to 4 kids.
You can't just like use up all my food,
use up all my shit, make a big fucking mess and like leave it for me.
You gotta fucking be a little bit respectful.
That's when everything started to deteriorate.
So I was like, alright, cool.
When the lease is over, we're just gonna part ways.
We parted ways and he was like, um.
I was like, I'm gonna.
He's like, get out as soon as you can cause my friends wanna move in.
I was like, cool,
got it. So I left,
you know, early.
I left two weeks early. And I was like, hey,
I'm gonna pay the portion of rent that I'm here
and then I'm gonna leave
you and your friends will take care of the rest.
He was like, yep, cool,
got it. I was like, cool,
I moved. And then he was like,
you didn't pay all the rent.
And I was like, yeah, bitch,
I'm paying a pro rated Rate?
I'm not gonna pay for the whole month.
So you and your friend, like,
trying to fucking constantly get me to pay for,
you know what I mean? Like,
wanting to live off of me,
wanting to use me. So since I only paid my pro rated portion,
the landlord was like, hey,
you know, you guys gotta pay the fucking rent.
And he was like, why isn't she paid?
He started, like,
making a big fuss, and I was like, Bud,
I have the fucking text message where I said
I'm gonna pay the perverted rate
where you're asking me to leave early.
And everything was cool,
and then all of a sudden he has a problem with it.
And I'm like, wow,
that sucks to suck, because I literally have it in writing.
You can't fucking do anything,
and I'm not gonna fucking pay the whole month rent
so you and your friends could live here alone.
Like, tell me how fucking alpha you are
that you want the woman to fucking pay for everything.
So I'm like, no,
that's not how it works.
So then what happens? My car first,
it was just the driver side window
and the driver side, like,
tail light got smashed. And I was like,
whatever, you fucking idiot,
I'll fix it. Well,
the kid that I babysit lives across the street,
and I have to drop him off at home sometimes,
and this motherfucker was outside and was like,
talking Shit to me the other day.
And I was like, whatever.
And drove by.
So stay the fuck away from those alpha men who, um,
you know, think that they're,
you know, that is where it should be.
Man is the man, and the woman is the woman,
blah, blah, blah.
Because when they get mad,
when they get angry,
they use their strength and power to hurt the woman.
And it doesn't matter how good you play along with them,
it doesn't matter how much you, like,
you know, try to appease them and be a good girl.
When they fucking get pissed,
they know that they're bigger,
they're stronger, and they could do what they want to you.
So just stay the fuck away from those types of men.
Stay the fuck away. I would so much rather have a fucking bear
than a fucking piece of shit.